oh CNBC drops a breaking Japan's topics
drops two percent Asia Pacific markets
fall as Credit Suisse adds to banking
fear I'm just sitting here like
tomorrow's gonna be good I think it's
worse than we realize I mean it could be
the thing like and so God damn it right
okay look you should have bought guns in
2020 when when like the Summer of Love
kicked off
um but anyways like I was saying there
are there are cryptos in existence that
are already uh pegged to the doll to the
value of the dollar
um so there's already a basic
infrastructure to have a dollar coin
right a dollar crypto that the that the
FED makes it's it's a simple transition
for them it is not hard at all the CR
the crypto wallets they can they can
design those and put those into make
them for your phone or whatever and and
I mean it's not a far step away